jule ist schwanger anwalt luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video auf meinen kanal in dem ich mich
bei einigen gerüchten stelle die über
mich so im internet kursieren warum
melde ich mich als wäre ich noch in der
schule ich habe euch bei instagram
gesagt dass er mir einige gerüchte
schreiben sollte ihr entweder von
freunden mitbekommen hast oder im
internet irgendwo gelesen hat und das
habt ihr tausendfach getan also ich
würde sagen wie verleger keine zeit und
fangen direkt an
mit dem ersten gerücht luca hatte mal
was mit katja meine fresse ich weiß wie
man darauf kommen können sonst hat ja
vor ein zwei jahren war ein video
hochgeladen haben sie gesagt hat haye
mit diesem youtuber hat dich was und
offen sein könnte man denken dass ich
das sei wenig aber nicht ich habe das
auch schon damals unter das video
geschrieben aber sagt es jetzt nochmal
ich hatte noch nie was mit katja und
werde auch nie mit ihr haben luca lässt
sich seine haare so lange wachsen bis er
sich einen kopf machen kann was ich hier
eventuell schon gemerkt habe dass ich im
moment meine haare ein bisschen länger
wachsen weil ich einfach noch nie lange
haare hatte
so richtig und ich weiß auch nicht wie
lange ich ihnen aufwachsen lassen werde
kann sein dass die nächste woche zum
friseur gehen und mir denke hey schneide
ich seit wieder komplett ab und oben
auch was aber jetzt gerade weil sie
nicht möglich hier einfach noch ein
bisschen länger wachsen aber ich habe
jetzt keine richtiges ziel vor augen von
wegen ich will einen zopf oder sobald
das mag ich eigentlich gar nicht so gern
luca kann meinungen anderer noch
schlecht akzeptieren das stimmt das
kurze leider recht zu geben wenn jemand
mehr kritik entgegen bringt und seine
meinung auch durch argumente stützt und
mir wirklich klar macht hey das ist der
grund warum ich so denke das ist der
grund warum ich richtig liege das
akzeptiere ich das aber wenn leute
einfach mit irgendwelchen meinungen
ankommen für die ich 20.000
gegenargumente findet dann sage ich
natürlich diese gegenargumente
ich bin halt nun mal ein mensch der sehr
darauf bedacht ist seine meinung
durchzubringen das ist eine eigenschaft
die mich auch schon in meiner schulzeit
oft einige probleme gebracht hat weil
ich immer der letzte war berichtete live
allerdings sehe ich das ganze eher
positiv an uns war es glaube ich noch
eigenschaft die mich eher weiter
vorangebracht hat
weil zum beispiel da darf ich jetzt kann
man gar nicht überreden aber wenn man
beispielsweise mit
sie kamen und handwerkern spricht und
dann sagt hey ich möchte gerne die
dielen in der wohnung haben und die
sagen das können wir machen wegen dem
schallschutz bodenaufbau man bleibt
einfach dran und bei knackig und liefert
den argumente von wegen haye klar muss
das gehen wir haben doch hier dies und
das und jeden tag sondern sagen ja wenn
du ja stimmt es geht doch dann hat man
nur durch seine hartnäckigkeit und halt
belegte argumente seinen willen
durchgekriegt also ja ich kann meinungen
von anderen eher schlecht akzeptiert
aber wenn es die richtige meinung ist
und die meinung ist gut begründet dann
habe ich dann natürlich respekt für
schule und luca werden bald heiraten
nehmt ihr denn soweit also irgendwann in
meinem leben möchte ich natürlich
heiraten und ich möchte auch irgendwann
kinder bekommen also ich kann ja keine
kinder bekommen aber jetzt gerade ist
das ganze noch überhaupt kein thema ich
bin gerade 23 geworden ich habe andere
es gerade in meinem kopf als heirat
hochzeiten cetera pp duca hast alle
anderen youtuber und macht deswegen
keine videos mit ihnen ja ich hatte
einfach alles und jeden also erst mal
stimmt das ja schon mal gar nicht ich
mache ja auch was mit anderen usern zum
beispiel mit rob habe ich ja schon
mehrere videos hochgeladen mit wieso
habe ich schon was gemacht weil julian
berg war ich in mehreren videos mit
dabei also ich mache schon auch videos
mit anderen youtube aber ist natürlich
verglichen mit anderen youtube in
deutschland mache ich sehr sehr sehr
sehr wenig kooperation weil ich halt
lieber ehrlich gesagt meine content
alleine mache ich bin glaube ich somit
der einzige in youtube deutschland der
seine videos noch selbst schneidet von
daher an alle die auch videos selbst
schneiden die wissen wie schwierig es
ist wenn andere leute mit dabei sind die
videos zu schneiden ich glaube dass das
wirklich auch ein großer faktor ist
warum ich meine videos oft alleine
aufnehme und ich bin auch oft nicht zu
hause sondern jetzt gerade auch bei
meiner familie und nehmen dann videos
oft um 38 morgens auf da findet man oft
auch keine anderen youtuber die dann
irgendwie mit einem dann video aufnehmen
luca hat angst vor spinnen das stimmt
ich habe panische angst vor spinnen luca
raucht nein ich bin der größte anti
raucher der welt denn freunde bei mir zu
ganzen und sagen hey wir geben auf dem
balkon rauchen dann mache ich auch alle
türen zu so das nicht irgendwie so ein
kleiner spalt offen ist weil ich rieche
es direkt mehr leute rauchen meine
mutter hat
früher ab und zu aus genuss einer
zigarette geraucht sind als ich noch
klein war noch zuhause gelebt habe ich
ihn niemand weggenommen und sekten
zählen auseinander gebrüstet und den
müll geschmissen weil ich nicht wollte
dass dir also ich bin wirklich der
allergrößte anti raucher der welt
natürlich habe ich auch als ich
irgendwie 18 waren wir kurz eine
zigarette gezogen einfach um es
auszuprobieren aber es war genau das was
ich mir schon gedacht hat und zwar
absolute scheiße bringt ein nächstes
einfach nur gesundheitsschädlich und
stinkt abgrundtief schlecht
von daher nein ich bin der größte an
sich auch gerade weil luca zieht nach
hamburg das stimmt tatsächlich den plan
nach hamburg zu ziehen habe ich schon
seit zwei jahren und jetzt hat sich das
vor ein paar monaten ein bisschen
konkretisiert weil wir ein cooles objekt
gefunden haben und julia und ich werden
voraussichtlich ende 2009 10 ende diesen
jahres nach hamburg ziehen oder halt
dann januar februar märz 2020 hinziehen
nicht aus köln weg weil wir köln blöd
finden ich bin der größte köln kann auf
der welt ist ist die freundlichste und
netteste und coolste stadt finde ich in
ganz deutschland allerdings wohl nicht
in köln mittlerweile seit mehr als vier
jahren und ich brauche einfach mal
wieder so ein gewissen tapetenwechsel
und ich freue mich schon sehr auf die
zeit in hamburg und ja genau also um das
gericht zurück zu kommen ja wir werden
nach hamburg sie jule ist schwanger nein
das ist mit das gerücht was mir am
meisten gesendet wurde
neben luca stimmt aber wie bereits
gesagt dass juden nicht schwanger wir
haben in absehbarer zeit nicht vor zu
heiraten oder auch mit kindern zu planen
also wir sind noch jung und möchten uns
das alles offen lassen aber jule ist
nicht schwach luca war mal im gefängnis
ich war zum glück noch nie im gefängnis
da ich tatsächlich ein mensch bin der
sich sehr sehr krass an regeln hält ich
habe einmal plastiklöffel im supermarkt
geklaut und nach fünf minuten zurück
gegeben weil ich angefangen habe zu
weinen ich habe vor ein paar wochen eine
anzeige reingekriegt weswegen ich erst
dachte dass ich vielleicht ins gefängnis
müsste aber das ganze war nur ein irrtum
und vielleicht wäre ich dazu auf dem
nächsten mal in einem video was zu sagen
aber ich will das jetzt nicht zu
hochschaukeln aber ich war noch nie im
gefängnis und werde hoffentlich ein lied
ein gefängnis gehen müssen luca hat mal
einen
krankenwagen wegen durchfall gerufen ja
ich hatte mal in den norovirus richtig
krank und habe heutzutage viel
flüssigkeit verloren und habe auch noch
gebrochen und saß allerdings auf dem klo
und dann konnte ich gar nicht richtig
laufen zittern ob krankenwagen rufen ins
krankenhaus gefahren und hatte dann eine
infusion bekommen
und jetzt geht es mir aber wieder gut
luca markt seine eigene pizza nichts
warum sollte ich denn die pizza
rausbringen wenn ich sie eigentlich gar
nicht mag ich finde und da muss ich
jetzt auch tatsächlich gerade werbevideo
hinschreiben obwohl es gar nicht mal
richtige werbung ist weil das produkt
luca pizza 2 ist ausverkauft wir haben
eine millionen pizzen verkauft also ihr
könnt es gar nicht mehr kaufen ich muss
wirklich sagen dass die luca fischer 2
und auch die bugspitze 1 die besten
pizzen waren die ig tiefkühl mäßig
gegessen habe klar beim italiener
irgendwie dann gibt's noch mal bessere
pizzen allerdings muss ich auch ganz
ehrlich gesagt zugeben dass ich von der
eu kapitza zwei mittlerweile fast 30
stück gegessen habe und deswegen gerade
so ein bisschen auch pizza entzug bin
und deswegen sie gerade nicht mehr so
viel konsumieren ich habe halt auch
leider keiner mehr zu hause sieht halt
aus lucka trinkt alkohol ja ich trinke
alkohol allerdings nicht mehr so ich sag
mal exzessiv wie ich das während meines
studiums gemacht habe jeder unter euch
der gerade studiert weiß wahrscheinlich
wie partymäßig die steppen zeit abgeben
ich ja leider das problem dass wir
irgendwann der ganze stress durch
praktikum youtube sport soziales leben
stress und mit party und alkohol et
cetera mir so zu schaffen gemacht hat
dass ich einen burnout holiday heart
syndrom mäßig so was hatte ge den
monaten danach habe ich gar keinen
alkohol konsumiert und mich dann sage
ich mal wieder langsam daran getastet
irgendwie auf der bachelor verhallt mal
mit einem sekt angestoßen oder mit papa
abends einen rotwein getrunken oder so
warum mittlerweile habe ich einen ganz
guten ausgleich in meinem leben gefunden
wo ich weiß hey ich brauche so und
soviel schild tage so viel zeit für
meinen körper dann ist doch vollkommen
okay wenn man mal in maßen alkohol
konsumiert und ja also ich trinke
alkohol luca ist millionär bei einigen
monaten hat ja jeder youtuber sein
einnahmen irgendwie offengelegt ich
selber redet nicht gerne über geld ich
frage euch nicht wie viel verdient und
wenn ihr es von mir wissen möchte dann
möchte ich euch darauf keine antwort
geben weil es mir und auch euch
eigentlich keinen vorteil bietet das
bringt es euch zu wissen herr luca
verdient 400.000 euro im monat oder luca
verdient 100 euro im monat also ich bin
ja immer noch der gleiche mensch luca
hat ein grundstück in den usa gekauft
was ich finde amerika cool wenn man im
winter nach new york fliegt es ist
wunderschön oder im sommer nach los
angeles oder nach miami zum party machen
oder so aber doch zu wuppen könnte ich
mir niemals vorstellen
ich könnte mir nie vorstellen irgendwie
deutschland als wohnort zu verlassen ich
bin so zufrieden hier luca ist schwul
ich bin heterosexuell und habe eine
freundin luca singt unter der dusche
tatsächlich bin ich glaube ich der
einzige mensch der noch nie unter der
dusche gesungen hat ich glaube meine
dusche würde sich instant abstellen wenn
sie mich singen hören würde luca hast
baby erstmal nicht atze gar keinen
menschen
ich habe so wie früher viele videos
hochgeladen weil ich ihren content
einfach komplett lächerlich finde sie
stellt das alles total überspitzter und
diese kunstfigur des beauty palace kann
ich wirklich überhaupt nicht ab bei dem
sie allerdings ein kind bekommen hat
sich auch ihr content leicht verändert
und das ist auch der grund warum ich
jetzt beispielsweise seit monaten schon
kein video mehr zu baby hochgeladen habe
weil ich finde dass sie sich leicht
gebessert hat also ich hasse bibi
keineswegs lukas zähne sind geblitzt das
ist wirklich neben judith schwanger und
luca stinkt das am meisten gepostete
gerücht von dem ihr denkt über mich dass
es war es die sind nicht geblitzt ich
esse nahezu gar keine schokolade ich
trinke gar keinen kaffee und ich rauche
nicht also das schlimmste was man seinen
zähnen eigentlich anfang an vermeiden
weil ich einfach nicht mehr und daher
sind meine zähne einfach so wie sie sind
und da bin ich auch sehr froh darüber
und ich nehme das einfach mal als
kompliment dass ihr denkt dass meine
zähne gebleicht sind aber stelle durch
das heutige video ist allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann das gerne einen
daumen hoch bei diesem video ihr da
schreibt mir gerne weitere gerüchte die
ihr über mich gehört habt und in die
kommentare vielleicht habe ich ja die
hälfte vergessen
da deutlich
[Musik]
ein